uh no the deadline for the Prime
Minister issues sunac to decide whether
to block Scotland's gender laws will
arrive this Wednesday the bill would
allow trans people to obtain a gender
recognition certificate without the need
for medical diagnosis
joined Now by campaigner Ellie gomasol
who is president of the national Union
of students in Scotland hello to you
it's good to see you thanks very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning subject very close to your
heart tell us about your journey through
transitioning
well I came out as trans when I was 18
and that was about five years ago now
I'm 23 now I had a really positive
experience
um all of my friends and family were
really really supportive
um I have to admit though I often joke
that the hardest thing about being trans
is the admin and I think there's a lot
of Truth to that it's been one of the
the biggest barriers one of the biggest
hurdles uh for me
um I've been able to update things like
my passport my driving license
Etc to to reflect my my name uh and my
my gender and the one thing that I've
not been able to do is update my birth
certificate and and that's because that
requires one of these gender recognition
certificates in order to do that that's
all the gender recognition certificate
does actually it allows you to update
your birth certificate and that means
that if you're getting married and you
can make sure that the marriage is being
recorded with you and you're correct
gender it means also that if you pass
away and that you can have dignity in
death by ensuring that the death
certificate is recorded correctly now
I've been not I've not been able to to
get that certificate and because I've
been on the waiting list for the NHS
gender identity clinics for that medical
diagnosis uh for coming up for five
years now I've not had an initial
appointment yet I'm still waiting I
don't know when that's going to be and
that means that under the current
process if I wanted to get that gender
recognition certificate to update my
birth certificate I would have to pay
for a private psychiatric assessment I
mean that costs hundreds of pounds on
top of all of the other costs related to
Gathering all of the the you know other
doc documents that they ask you to
submit to this sort of panel of
so-called experts who will never
actually meet you to determine whether
you're man enough or woman enough to
update your birth certificate and so
that's been a real barrier to me and so
I was really really excited and really
happy that the the the bell in Scotland
that you know we've been campaigning on
for so so long uh finally passed back in
December to make that process just a
little bit easier
can you when you are 16 years old
know that
this sort of decision that will change
your life forever is the right one
I think you absolutely can I mean I
certainly did I didn't come out until I
was 18. uh but I think I always knew uh
that I was trans and actually there's so
many uh young trans kids uh whose
transitioned you know some of them at
Primary School they've lived you know
the vast majority of their lives by the
time that they're 16 uh and that their
new gender
um and I think what's really important
when we're talking about this particular
bill is that all it is is about updating
your birth certificate that's all that
the gender recognition certificate does
we're not talking about Medical
Treatments here we're not talking about
anything else we're talking about a
piece of paper which you know worst case
scenario if uh you know years later down
the line actually realize you know what
that wasn't right for me and you know
that that's not gonna change your entire
life uh if you need to change that back
so we are just talking about a bit of
paper here and I think when we're
talking about 16 17 year olds in
particular I mean right now in Scotland
16 year olds can vote in Scottish
elections can get married and you can
have a child you can join the Army I
think you know a lot of those last
couple of ones you know that that's a
much bigger impact on your life uh than
you know updating the the gender that's
marked on your birth certificate so I
think that not only is 16 young enough I
think that actually in the cases where
you know kids have been living in their
current gender for for almost their
entire lives at some point the majority
of their their childhoods actually I
think that the bill doesn't go far
enough and there does need to be
provision in the future for for younger
people to be able to with the support
you're in the right guidance and advice
be able to update uh you know their
birth certificates to get that gender
recognition certificate as well because
if you're a trans young person who's
been you know at school a lot of maybe
the kids are at high school if you
transition to primary school don't even
know that you're trans and then maybe
you're going to college or university
for the first time or getting your first
job you don't have any other forms of ID
and having to present that that birth
certificate that has the wrong name and
gender on it I think can be really
difficult and stigmatizing for for that
young person do you feel that given that
you know you're an expert on this matter
do you feel that you could put a number
on that age limit
well I I think that uh you know it's
something that that needs to be looked
at in more detail
um I think you know I I couldn't say
because you know I wasn't a kid myself
when I did uh come out exactly what that
age should be but I think that that you
know a lot of uh campaigners are talking
about you know sort of uh you know 10 uh
that sort of age
um but you know I think that the point
is is that we've not looked into this
enough uh about you know kids who are
under 16 but we have talked for a very
very long time about 16 17 year olds in
Scotland I mean this discussion has been
going on for about six seven years now
uh since the the leaders of all of the
the parties in the Scottish Parliament
including the conservative party uh
first committed to these reforms so I
think that that we've had so many years
of consultation and talking about this
issue that that I think that we have you
know reached a solid conclusion here on
16 17 Euro worlds and we need to have
more discussions about younger people
than that to make sure that those those
people in the future are able to access
gender recognition certificates as well
as you know zakias Dharma does not agree
with you he thinks that 16 is too young
for a young person to decide on
paperwork when it relates to their
gender and we know that the British
government also has concerns about the
bureaucracy of having different roles in
Scotland than for the rest of the union
and could in fact as a result block this
bill what would you say to the Prime
Minister this morning
or I would say look at the Belt look at
what it actually does look at where it
actually changes uh the the law and I
think when we've been talking about this
bill and in particular uh the lines that
have been coming from the UK government
all relate uh to the equality act the
equality act 2010
um which is the the law that you know
puts into place uh you know
anti-discrimination uh measures Etc
um it's the law that currently means
that you know trans people are able to
to access spaces for instance that match
the gender that we are rather than the
sex that we were assigned at Birth
um and I think that that you know all of
these conversations don't actually
relate to the really simple process of
updating your birth certificate which is
what this uh what this bill actually
does I I think that that you know we've
ended up getting into all of these
conversations about different Provisions
that the bill doesn't actually change so
what I'd say to both the Prime Minister
and to to kierstama is look at what the
bill actually does and listen to the
people who have been looking at this for
years particularly to to cure starmer I
mean you know the Scottish labor party
fully supported these reforms Mark
Drakeford the first minister of Wales
has also said that you know if Wales had
the same Powers as Scotland then this
would be something that the Welsh
government should be looking at as well
and you know in the conservatives
Theresa May has supported these reforms
and a number of Scottish conservative
msps also voted for the bill back in
December so I say listen to the people
who have been working on this for years
look at the legislation look at what it
does and doesn't do and I think that
once you've done that the facts are
really simple yeah I mean I'm not sure
that it's completely correct to say that
it was fully supported by the labor
party in Scotland it wasn't fully
supported by the SNP as well really if I
could quote Joanna Cherry to you from
the SMP not at all happy about women's
safety and what may happen as a result
of this bill
she says the bill will allow any man to
declare himself a woman and to gain the
legal status of woman for all or most
purposes after three months of living as
a woman what it means to live as a woman
is also left undefined and some using
that as an example of
previously being recognized as a man now
being recognized as a woman and being
potentially in a woman's jail
well I think there's a lot of things to
to unpack here first of all I think that
it's right that we don't have a
state-defined definition
um of what Womanhood means I think that
would be really dangerous not just for
Trans people but for for women across
the country
um if there was a strict set of
guidelines as to what it meant to to be
a woman that would be really worrying
when it comes to things like jails again
that's something that's covered under
the equality act 2010 this bill doesn't
change that and if you actually look at
again the equality act 2010 if you look
at section uh sorry paragraph 28 of the
equality act there's a specific section
in there which talks about when there is
a legal need to still be able to
discriminate so that means that when
we're talking about things like jail for
instance you know if there was a genuine
threat uh for example for someone going
to say a women's prison
um then under the equality act that can
still be broken and that's regardless of
whether you've got a gender recognition
certificate or not it doesn't come into
it so I I think that when we're then
talking about uh you know whether or not
a man would be able to to fraudulently
claim that he was a woman and get a
gender recognition certificate I'd ask
well why on Earth would a predatory man
do that why would they go through that
process of getting a piece of paper that
allows them to update their birth
certificate that doesn't change their
access to things like Single Sex spaces
for instance all it does is it means
that you know the birth certificate now
says that they're a woman if they were
to get married they'd be recorded as a
bride and their death certificate would
say that they were a woman I don't see
any reason why any predatory man would
see that as as a bonus or a way to to
access uh you know being being a
predator okay
um eloquently Paul Ellie it's good to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
this morning I appreciate it thank you